bonjour et bienvenue dans cette émission
qui comme vous avez pu vous en rendre
compte à changer de nom pour faire écho
à la nouvelle formule du petit quentin
le magazine de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui a fait peau neuve en
novembre pour le reste pas de grands
bouleversements vous retrouverez
toujours chaque mois notre dossier et
nos actus et on débute tout de suite
avec un zoom sur l'université
j'en ai en fac d'économie et gestion en
deuxième année et
les profits sont ces passionnés je
trouve que je me sens très bien suivre
on permet de bien intégrer au niveau de
l'enseignement ça se défend aussi je
trouve qu'on a des formations qui sont
assez diversifiés
il ya beaucoup d'activités
donc là
la ville sont très bête a sauté des mac
c'est toujours une super ambiance et des
cours de danse et au fond c'est agréable
de venir tous les jours pour les
événements ne sais pas ce souci-là dans
l'année je suis top ici à tout sinon
ciel on a le petit parc pour manger le
midi quand il fait beau et sinon des
petits restos à côté ça franchement on
est bien placé chevaux moi j'avais
arrivé donc je connais pas tellement
l'université mais c'est vrai que par
rapport au cadre c'est quand même assez
joli ça donne envie de travailler
c'est beaucoup organisés que là où
j'étais avant on a des bons enseignants
donc tout avoir et oui tout va bien pour
les vingt mille étudiants de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines inscrits dans
plus de 200 formations
pluridisciplinaires proposé dans un
campus agréable temps fort de la rentrée
le nouveau bâtiment de l'ufr des
sciences de la santé a ouvert ses portes
à montigny le bretonneux
le terrain était donnée gratuitement par
la communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a également
financé sa construction à hauteur de 6
millions d'euros
ah oui quand
tous les acteurs locaux énormément
favoriser le fait financièrement qu'on a
pu avoir cette faculté
certes et maintenant qu'elle existe une
petite présentation peut-être en
première année de passagers sont entrés
852 professeur université à peu près 90
et 250 chercheurs savent à peu près 12
cents d'étudiants en permanence sur sur
le site
ce n'est plus seulement des études
médicales mais il ya les des sciences
qui sont des sciences de la santé c'est
à dire les autos logis les dentistes la
pharmacie la maïeutique c'est à dire les
sages-femmes et puis après on décline
des professions qui sont les
psychothérapeutes les ergothérapeutes et
manip radio les kinés et donc tout ça
c'est des professions qui sont associés
et que l'on ne perd pas il ya aussi bien
sûr les infirmières et tout ceci est
regroupé pour que les 1000 où ils sont
50 plus exactement étudiants au début
des études d'après soit ventilés en
fonction de l'heure le numerus clausus
et de leurs notes vers les créneaux d
aux métiers de la santé il a deux
grandes catégories de l'avant qui sont
regroupés il ya des quatre catégories de
biologistes et puis un deuxième grand
groupe qui est plutôt de l'épidémiologie
et c'est un groupe s'appelle reese et
c'est une des particularités de ce de
cette faculté d'avoir ces deux grands je
dirais moteurs qui sont la biologie la
recherche ou bio moléculaire et
l'épidémiologie des labos qui sont de
grands espoirs pour la recherche mais en
ufr des sciences de la santé sur le
territoire
c'est aussi un plus pour tous les saint
quentinois ce qui peut être plus
intéressant c'est d'imaginer
l'implantation des médecins locaux c'est
à dire quand on forme des médecins
généralistes
ce qui est très intéressant dans
l'environnement actuel c'est d'avoir des
médecins généralistes qui vont
s'installer autour de la faculté bien
évidemment et tous les métiers de la
santé que l'on va former ici c'est c'est
aussi un grand atout c'est à dire les
kinésithérapeutes ergothérapeutes les
manips radio les infirmières toute hâte
c'est le grand intérêt d'avoir une
faculté de des sciences de la santé mais
pas seulement parce qu'il ya tous les
autres métiers de la santé dont on a
besoin
bienvenue donc à l'ufr des sciences de
la santé mais toujours à la pointe de la
recherche du vs qu est une université
d'avenir qui développe également de
nombreux autres points forts à monsieur
baissière justement vous chercher les
points forts entre l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
c'est sa jeunesse puisque la fêter ya
pas très longtemps ses 21 ans
donc ça ses fils et universités
dynamique universités donc ils capables
innovations en termes de formation
effectivement nous avons beaucoup de
formations qu'on a t'elle professionnels
souvent présentes en apprentissage nous
avons également
donc en termes de recherche beaucoup de
relations de recherche et développement
en partenariat avec l'industriel sur des
contrats industriels pour promouvoir
l'innovation nord qui est très
importante pour la compétitivité du
territoire mais également du pays' de
rénovation si en terme de recherche
puisque on est capable d'investir sur ce
qu'on appelle ce que j'appelle des
niches je pourrais citer sur
l'environnement développement durable
sur la cryptologie sur les matériaux sur
la sociologie de la délinquance et etc
etc
quelques exemples qui permet
d'identifier merci de versailles saint
quentin
alors ce qui est très important c'est le
partenariat aussi donc j'évoquais tout à
l'heure les partenariats avec le monde
socio économique à travers une formation
professionnelle dans l'apprentissage
j'ai évoqué également dans le même
registre et partenariats en recherche
développement avec les crises
entreprises l'industrie nous avons
quelques fleurons déchets industriels
iphone parties prenantes dany eu des bd
comme en lien avec le monde de
l'automobile
ce qui est plus important de pâtes
horaire c'est celui que nous pouvons
avoir avec les collectivités
territoriales et je pourrais citer donc
le partenariat fort nous avons avec la
communauté d'agglomération saint quentin
en yvelines également conseil général
des yvelines qui sont mdd soutien très
fort et nous avons vraiment la volonté
que ce soit un partenariat c'est à dire
que nous contribuons nous développement
social économique et culturel de ces
territoires
enfin dernière acceptant des
partenariats ce sont les partenariats
académiques dont on peut prendre comme
exemple le partenariat plus nous
développons au sein du projet du rc
paris ça paye campus tacler et à ceux ci
dix écoles qui associe cet organisme de
recherche à caractère national et
deuxième cité par le daily mail nous
sommes membres fondateurs de ce qui est
encore aujourd'hui une fondation de
coopération scientifique
nous sommes également membre de l'idex
ap et là nous sommes partie prenante de
la création de l'université paris ça
fait qu'il doit être le neubourg et
fiches pu dire au 1er janvier 2014
mais outre les structures et les cours
dispensés un autre point d'importance
concerne les étudiants qui viennent à
saint quentin en yvelines le logement à
l'horizon 2013-2014 de nouvelles
résidences ouvriront ainsi à elancourt
lui au cours et montigny le bretonneux
il propose aux 798 chambres
supplémentaires de la création de 50 ans
nul et une pour nous avoir universités
sur notre territoire était fondamental
événement fondamental si on croit à
l'avenir de son directoire on doit
croire en laminant saint-genès il a dit
aux agences passe par la formation par
la formation de qualité et donc pas une
université de qualité
on a investi dans cette université avec
vers salle afin d'avoir des laboratoires
de recherche des étudiants une formation
de qualité mais en plus ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que les étudiants restent
sur le territoire vivent sur le
territoire et pour cela il fallait que
je crée
lens étudiants des milieux de vie pour
qu'ils puissent rester à mu notre
territoire et en fin de compte et au
coeur de la ville 50 en est maintenant
on retrouve nos actus du bois tu viens
spectateurs
et l'on début de saison actuelle avec
une extension en effet suite à une phase
de test grandeur nature renault a lancé
auprès du public son service
d'autopartage en partenariat avec la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
après inscription les titulaires du
permis b auront désormais accès aux 50
twizy déployés à montigny guyancourt
voisins et sur une partie des trains
chronique prenez date dès maintenant les
entreprises de tous secteurs d'activité
et les collectivités territoriales ont
rendez vous le 4 décembre avec les
étudiants et jeunes diplômés de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en plus des
offres de stages et d'emplois proposés
ce forum mettra l'accent sur l'emploi
des étudiants en situation de handicap
et pour finir plus de lignes plus de
rotations plus de secteurs desservis
plus de correspondances avec les trains
à compter du 12 novembre le réseau
stibus évolué pour mieux répondre aux
attentes des habitants et des salariés
de saint quentin en yvelines une
optimisation opérées dans le cadre du
plan de déplacement inter entreprises de
la zone d'activités de trappes et
l'encours et qui concerne un vaste
secteur entre les gares de trappes et de
la verrière des améliorations qui
toucheront les lignes 400 2 415 430 et
431 un dossier que vous pouvez retrouver
dans le petit quentin du mois de
novembre c'est qu'un article sur la
nageuse chloé delcamp et un autre sur le
boom du tai-chi-chuan quant à nous et
bien on se retrouve votre fonctionnement
dans le kiosque pour parler de tous nos
rendez vous culturel du moment à bientôt